yeah i want to talk to you today about
my experience using daytonic on a
project that i'll describe
um along the way i want to get into some
of the details of how
i can have come to think about daytonic
because i think having that model in
mind is super helpful but the context of
a real world application
i think will set the stage very well you
heard my name i just want to mention a
couple things
there's my twitter handle my email i
always tell people anybody
that is able to sit through me talking
for a while earns the right to email me
for the rest of their lives with
whatever questions they might have so uh
if you stick to daytonic or closure
stuff you'll probably get good answers
but if you do need advice on whether to
do an adjustable rate mortgage i'll give
it a shot
i'm also the host of the podcast
formerly the
think relevance the podcast uh now the
cognicast
so we talk about all sorts of things
related to software engineering and
daytonic certainly comes up from time to
time so
you can check it out at that url the
project that i uh
the real world project that we're going
to discuss today is a project that
i as a consultant worked with one of our
clients accompanying room key
they are in the as you might guess the
hotel industry
they provide consumers a search engine
whereby they can discover
rooms at various hotels based on
location criteria and other things
i just want to mention them because it
was it's been really great to work with
them i really appreciate them
letting me use this application as
background for the talk
there's their url we actually had them
on the podcast
on talking about this application
was more of kind of the business side
like how they were
how they came to use atomic but i put a
quick link up there if you wanted to
happen to to listen to that so
um let's jump into the problem we were
trying to solve okay so like i said room
keys in the hotel industry and
um i'm going to simplify the problem a
little bit the system's a bit bigger but
the essential details remain
that uh we have users and we're trying
to
provide to another part of the system
summary information about the sales
funnel
people come to the site and they're
shown a list of hotels you might type in
st louis and you get a whole bunch of
hotels uh that is
called in a slightly uh
way that's irregular relative to the way
most people talk about impressions we
call that the impression so that would
be
oh we just showed the user these 25
hotels the user might then click on one
of those hotels
and get details about that hotel from
there they might click on the hotel with
the intention to book a room we call
that a lead
and then if they go through with the
process and book the room there's
booking so we're gathering these events
in and we want to
store them somewhere we chose the atomic
obviously and then later
uh as part of another part of the system
that we use to
do various things actually we want a
summary
of counts well we want a count of those
events
by type per hotel per day right so i
want to know that there were 35
impressions for the times square
marriott
on you know september 5th right
this is the problem now if you if you do
the numbers you can see them right there
there's a fair amount of data here this
is not um you know stretching the bounds
of what people are doing with big data
but you got you know 30 days
20 events per second there's an average
of five hotels per event
although the only one that has more than
one hotel associated with is the
impression but
you know you just kind of add it up you
get 250 million hotel events
they need to sift through all right and
we want to be able to do
to answer questions about those
summaries in real time so there are some
some challenges here because that's a
fairly again i wouldn't necessarily
characterize this as a big data problem
but it's a problem with a fair amount of
data
when you want to work with it
transactionally because we do actually
want to be able to
answer questions about how many events
there were of this type on this day for
this hotel
as part of processing a request that
we're using to serve
user interface to the users of the
website okay
so like i said we chose to use daytonic
just a quick show of hands
who here has at least downloaded
daytomic and play with it a little bit
all right great so a fair number of
people so i think some of you seen the
docs i i do have
you know 40 minutes to cover both an
application a solution using it and then
all of the atomic concepts so i'm going
to move through this stuff fairly
quickly
but it is worth putting the atomic
architecture slide up here because
there are some differences from other
databases that you may have used that
are not atomic
the main one is that well i don't know
if i'd say
the main one but certainly a difference
is that uh here's your app right the
code that you write
and there are things that happen here in
this process specifically
query right all the queries actually run
in your process
as opposed to sending them off to some
database server somewhere and that's
that's achieved that actually has a
number of nice properties
and it's achieved because the atomic
takes the approach of splitting apart
things that are typically together
specifically when you have a traditional
database you have one place where you go
and that's where the data
lives and that's where you send in new
information and that's where you go to
ask questions you actually send your
question over there
so you'll notice how in daytonics is
blown up the data lives in some storage
service right down here
okay the application up here does query
locally
query communicates directly with the
storage service so we don't actually
need this other piece called the
transactor
which is where updates happen we send
all of our we want to add information
the application sends it to the
transactor
which is where coordination happens the
data is actually stored in storage
okay so it's really kind of blowing
apart the traditional database
now you know just briefly you can
observe one of the advantages here is
that
scaling read is actually a matter of
simply adding more
nodes where your application is running
and the atomic terminology um
the the application is appear it's the
atomic appears the thing that
that runs your application code okay so
i think if you look sounds like a lot of
people have seen uh daytonic
that this is probably mostly review but
i wanted to throw up here is kind of
level set
okay so let's dive down a little bit um
how does atomic see the world
the atomic sees the world it sees a
database as a collection of
datums right where each datum is a tuple
and the tuple has um to a first order uh
four
four uh uh four aspects there's the
entity attribute value and the time
the entity is the thing that we're
modeling right
it's roughly analogous to a row in a you
know
square a rectangular database right or
if you're on a
rdf person uh subject predicate object
this would be the subject it's the thing
we're talking about
in our system it's going to be what it's
going to be things like hotels we're
going to say
a hotel is an entity or an event
is an entity it's the thing that we're
talking about the thing that we're
modeling
and those each of those entities can
have
uh you know one or more datums that talk
about them and we use
attributes to describe some some aspect
of that entity
right hotel might have a location right
so there's an
attribute that describes locations of
things um and then
there's a value that says the actual
quantity or quality
the location would be times square um
and now here's
so that's all you know fairly
straightforward the one thing that
daytonic adds that you don't see too
many other places is the notion of time
right so each of those tuples has a time
or really a transaction which is
effectively when we learn that fact
right it correlates to a wall clock time
it's not actually serialized that way
but if you have these these tuples you
know you have facts that include all
these things what are we talking about
what's you know what or what aspect that
are we describing what's the actual
quality or quantity and when did we
learn it okay so
get an example here yesterday as part of
a transaction that happened at
you know 302 pm i learned that craig
likes pizza what's sanity craig
what's the attributes things that he
likes
and what's the value pizza and then
there's a time or a transaction
right we really record time at the
transaction level now notice
um what this gives us is a database
where
you only ever add facts right
we put a fact and we say here's when we
learned it in daytonic
we never really go back and say it
doesn't mean
it's hard to even say in english right
like today
i un this thing that i learned i
it turns out i no longer learned that
you can add facts that modify things
you've already learned
today at 3 10 i learned that craig no
longer likes pizza
but you would do that by adding datums
to the database right so we can really
see the database as this
huge list of these tuples well maybe not
huge this is a list of these tuples
that describe you know things that we
know something about and that we learned
at some time
okay does that make sense again we're
moving through this fairly quickly
because i want to make sure we talk
about
the problem but we do want to discuss
attributes because these are pretty
interesting an
attribute uh we talked about you know
craig likes pizza so this is sort of the
likes part
um they have a type right an ident which
is essentially a name
and a cardinality so cardinality would
be you know um
is can there only be one datum about
likes or can craig like
many things um now the types include the
stuff you'd expect
strings numbers dates whatever
um there's also however significantly an
attribute can have a type of ref okay
and when an attribute has a type of ref
its value is the id of another entity
it's really it's a number the value is
physically a number but it's meant to be
interpreted as
that thing over there there was an event
someone booked a room at that hotel
we're gonna have an entity in the
database
we're gonna have a datum that talks
about the event the value is going to be
right the attribute would be you know
the hotel this event is associated and
the value would be
a ref to another hotel so what does this
mean this means that
you can see this list of of tuples as
forming a graph
right so it's very powerful right you
can model all sorts of relationships
this way
yeah and and the last line is
significant schema
in daytonic is simply the list of
attributes and we we don't actually have
a notion in the atomic of um of entity
type
so i made i made distraction let me go
ahead and just move on to the uh
the schema that we used in our
application right so here's an
example of the attributes some of the
attributes that we used
we have an attribute for example called
uh roomkey.hotel
id and this is a convention that is not
enforced but that we typically follow
where uh we name attributes via keywords
that are namespace
the namespace is the part that appears
before the slash and it is
uh typical to give that to make that
namespace
be congruent with the type the type of
entity that we're describing now
entities don't have a type
at the atomic level but we often
notionally have we're going to have
entities in the database that that are
modeling
hotels where other entities are going to
be modeling you know events things that
happened
at uh about those hotels and so you can
see we would define some of our
attributes
with a namespace the bit that appears
before the slash that's room key.hotel
and some that are
roomkey.event meaning that we intend for
those attributes to be
part of datums whose entity is
modeling a hotel in the case of the
first attribute
or an event in the case of the other
three so it kind of makes sense but it's
just convention there's nothing in the
atomic that actually prevents you from
saying
this entity which notionally you know
conceptually models an event
has an attribute of you know room key
dot hotel slash id you could do that it
wouldn't
mean anything but the atomic's view is
you know if you're gonna
we'll let you say anything you want to
even if it doesn't necessarily make
sense in the context
context of your application and that
flexibility actually turns out to be a
real asset
okay so let's look at these real quick
um so a hotel has an id it's a string
mentioned briefly in the last slide that
you can
provide some uh some additional
characterizations of attributes one of
them is uniqueness right
so what does that mean that means that
only one entity
in the database can have hotel id
with a particular value right times
square marriott
right or whatever we're using for ids
okay that's a constraint that atomic
will enforce
um what else we're going to model we're
going to model events events are going
to have a type
the type is a ref i'll talk about why
that is in a minute
cardinality single right there it can
only reference one type events can't
say you can't have two datums in the
database where you say
this this event you know that is modeled
by entity 5678
has there's a datum that says that
entity
attribute type value something and then
another datum that says
same entity same attribute different
value that's what cardinality single
means you can't have two datums with the
same
entity and attribute but with different
values at the same time
all right uh hotels we have uh is also a
ref
meaning we're going to have datums in
the database where the
entity identifies some event the
attribute is what hotels
are about that event and the value is
a list of some other entities right
remember because you could have an
impression
we showed a user like 25 events so we
would say oh well there's a datum in the
database for each of the hotels
that this event is associated with and
then of course there's a time
when the event occurred and we'll get
back uh to that when we come around to
how we actually solve the problem
does this all make sense all right so
here's a picture of that i've kind of
put the entity types again they're
notional not
not realized in the database on the left
here we have um
actually let's come back to that in a
second so we have events here in the
middle um
events uh there's an each of these kind
of rectangles with a blue top and a
green bottom represents an
entity and then we have attribute value
pairs so each of these
kind of rows here represents a datum
right because the datums are actually
tuples e-a-v-t
so for this entity id we would have a
tuple that would have an attribute
this type and i've abbreviated these
right remember we usually use name
spaces but to fit it on the slide this
is actually room
key dot event slash type um the type is
one two three let's go back to that in a
second the time is you know some time
and then notice that we've got a hotel
remember those are refs
so what is this value it's actually the
id of another entity so
so what we actually got here is what a
graph
right that 8765 points to
another entity which itself has
a datum whose attribute is id and whose
value is you know whatever id we're
using hotel one or something
okay now notice the other thing we've
done here is this is
also somewhat idiomatic and atomic is um
to model
types we've actually if you recall
here we said that type is a ref okay
what we did is we said that there are
these singleton
essentially datums in the database that
is we cause a
we put a datum in the database that
represents the event type
okay so here we've got and then we give
it a an attribute which is one of the
built-in
um attributes dbi dent that just kind of
gives us a way to talk about it in human
readable language
right so this is the impression this is
the the one data in the database that
represents impression events or the
impression event type
that one for details one for lead one
for booking and then when we want to say
an event is of a type
we just add a datum whose entity
is the event we're talking about whose
attribute is type and whose value is
the entity id of the datum that
represents that type now why would i
want to do that
and we'll come back to this but the
reason is that all of these ref
relationships this graph
they're all traversable in either
direction so we can go
from this event to
the entity that represents that event
type
or the other way which gives us a nice
convenient way to say
tell me all of the events that are of
type impression because we can follow
those arrows in both directions
this makes sense and we're going to come
back to how that's implemented and how
you can think about that as the talk
progresses we talked about indexes
so again this is a somewhat simplified
version of the problem we're solving but
actually all the fundamentals
all the salient points are here this
really is essentially the problem we
were solving was to
to capture a whole bunch of events and
then the question was how can you walk
back up to this
uh later and ask questions about
you know oh hotel 8765 how many
impressions were there and to
navigate through this graph and get a
summary of that data
right good cool
all right so um to in order to talk
about how
how we achieve that i want to talk some
more about um how this stuff
is actually implemented in uh daytonic
and i'll i'll admit to doing um that's
not really beta and switch but
um i i may have lured you in a bit with
the title real world dynamic we really
are discussing a real problem that we
solved
but the thing i actually want you to
walk away from here
is an understanding of of how daytonic
stores and retrieves data
because i suspect that you are not
writing a hotel system that is capturing
events and want to do queries over them
whatever you do however
you you will benefit greatly from
understanding how
daytonic organizes this information
because it makes almost everything about
the atomic
kind of fall into place and makes sense
um
uh so i i wanna i wanna spend a little
bit of time in the middle here and it'll
actually enable us to talk about a
really neat feature of the atomic that
we did wind up using to solve our
problem and by talking about indexes i
think we're going to arm you with
both to understand that and then to go
forth and use that for your own problems
all right so we have these um these
datums and the way they get into the
database is that
the application says okay there's an
event um and it's got this
attribute type and its value is you know
whatever corresponds to impression
and you know it's got a time and it's
got these hotels and so
you make up these entity attribute value
tuples
and you and notice there's no t in a
second and you package them up and you
send them off to the transactor and
that's
your transaction your transaction is a
set of those eav tuples
and the transactor which again is that
that piece that was down here in the
architecture diagram
takes them and it says okay those all
belong together they're all single
transaction
let me make sure you know let me add a t
to that because remember
all the datums that are actually in the
database we write down when we learned
that we write down when
the transactor found out about them we
so we generated t attach it to all those
now we've got our datums our eavt
put them in the log right durably store
it because it's a database right you've
got to do that right you put it in the
log
you know that's atomic so that either
succeeds or it all fails it's good thing
um and so that's that's in the log right
at that point you know you've got it
down on on on some some storage
somewhere
um and actually i mentioned this but
daytonic supports
multiple different storages you can
actually have your data physically live
in a
in a variety of different stories we
were using uh amazon's dynamodb because
the room key application is hosted in
the amazon cloud it's very convenient a
very scalable solution
but uh it doesn't really matter for the
rest of our discussion um so it's put in
the log and you can actually think of
the log as the database right
because it's got all the facts in it
here's everything we learned
uh it's in time order which is probably
not the most convenient
for our problem it's actually not bad
but you can imagine
that it's not going to be the best
structure to
to to do query for every application you
don't really want to have to go through
and say let's see
the way i figure out how many events
there were for this hotel is to start
at the beginning of time and look
through everything that this database
has ever learned
every time i answer a question and uh
just kind of you know accumulate an
answer
right probably not the best approach so
what atomic does
is in addition to storing the data in
the log
all datums are also stored redundantly
the whole datum
is also stored in indexes
okay now what's an index um
[Music]
i got to say the second bullet here uh
are is like the six words that
uh rich hickey uh the creator of
daytonic uh said to me
about ten months ago that made the
atomic make sense
and index is a sorted set of datums okay
seven words whatever right an index is a
sorted set of datums right
some small number of words that actually
is i believe the key to understanding
the atomic
so and that's really it like we have
these datums and datums are just an
entity attribute value time
okay and we're going to take them and
put them in a set
right in the mathematical sense right
and they're going to be in some order
um and the order that they're in um
is varies by the index there's actually
several indexes you can see the list of
four of them the right there e-a-v-t
a-a-v-t-a-v-e-t and v-a-e-t
wow i said that right um and
there's one more called the full text
index and with
the the me saying that there exists a
full text insect represents the entire
extent to which i understand anything
about that one so you can corner rich
later or come to me and we'll find
someone that can explain that better but
the these four indexes e a v t a e v t a
v e t and v a e t
store uh either all or some of the
datums and we'll get into exactly which
ones store which
in the order name so the eavt index
unsurprisingly stores things first by
entity id then by attribute then by
value then by time
and because they're sorted we can get to
any point that we want into them
efficiently
right makes sense okay
so the eavt and the aevt index
get every datum so every data that you
send to the database everything goes in
the log of course
all the datums also go into the eavt and
aevt index
this means that from a storage
perspective you're storing everything at
least
three times but you know
when you know companies can afford to
just like throw an eight gigabyte you
know flash drive at you we've moved
beyond the point where
storage is you know usually the limiting
cost in a system
so there's a lot of benefit to be had by
doing this and
the if you think about those two indexes
you think of the sort order it makes
perfect sense why you would
want those two things the eavt index
sorts first by entity
id then by attribute then by value then
by time if you think about that what
that means is that it's very efficient
to walk up
to the index and go up entity whatever
and then okay everything about all the
datums about that entity are together
so you can find out all the information
about a particular entity
efficiently right what does that remind
you of in us maybe a traditional
database
it's kind of like a row right you have a
row it's a bunch of facts about a
particular thing avt it's a bunch of
datums a bunch of facts about a
particular
thing about a particular entity right
and conversely or maybe it's not
conversely i forget the definition of
converse but
also we have aevt right which stores
first by attribute so you can walk up
and say oh
uh you know let's say i've got you know
entities in this database that represent
people
let me go find the part of the aev tn
that talks about first names
attribute first name oh here are all the
first names in the database if you like
or some subset thereof
okay what's that like if eavt is like a
row oriented view what's aavt like
column oriented view right and we always
have both of these
so you can pick which one is more
efficient
for your needs okay
so this is just like a you know
to visualize a little bit better you can
see we've got our datums each one of
these rows is effectively a datum ea vt
and you can see
in the eavt index we sort first by e
right so all the all the datums about
the event one entity come together and
then all the
datums about the event two entity come
together and then we sort by a and then
by v and then by t
right so there's hotel now in point of
fact atomic is not storing them
as you know angle bracket e
v e and t right these things are all
stored in a different form where the
the the the e that we're storing is
actually the id of an entity and we'll
get more
in a minute in a little while um to
exactly uh what the advantages that are
so this is really a more realistic view
of what's actually in the database but
i think conceptually you know this is a
reasonable way to
to think about it and we'll we'll we're
going to use this representation going
forward
and so then very similarly here's the
aevt index right notice that here
everything is together by attributes so
all the hotels are together all the time
together all the types are together
and then we sort by e right
all right so what about the other two
the other two you don't always get
uh the av et index which is the only one
that's actually pronounceable avet
um only stores datums where we have
defined the attribute
uh to be marked with db index true so
we've said
we want this attribute to all datums
that are
the where the a is this attribute to be
in the avett index which makes sense a
v e t first name craig right
a v my first store by a first name v
is craig those will all be together so
now i have an easy way if i know the a
and the v
to go and look up all the entities that
have that that's kind of what you'd
expect
index true to mean right
and then there's v-a-e-t which is also
called the reverse index and you only
get this one
for attributes that you defined whose
type is ref
okay and this is what allows us to
traverse relationships in reverse
remember i said you can always go
from an event to the hotels that it
talks about or from the hotel
back to the events that are connected to
it and that's because
in a ref datum the e
is maybe the event the a is the ref
attribute
and the v is what the hotel entity if
you switch those
e and the v reverse index it's just the
same information
pointing in the other way so the same
datum just organized differently
gives us that reverse relationship make
sense
okay cool and then this is you know
nothing special here
just notice that unlike the previous
slide not all of the datums are here
only the datums
for the attribute marked index
true wind up in the avett index and
similarly only the attributes of type
ref
wind up in the reverse index all right
so now it's not the case that we store
the datums in the index and then pull
them back one of a time if you remember
from the architecture slide
your application's running up here
storage is down here
right there's a cache but you know maybe
your database isn't big enough to fit in
the cache
so you occasionally have to go across
the network it would be silly
if you had to go and pull one datum back
at a time so datums are actually stored
in these chunks
compressed called segments and the
segments are organized
as a tree which is how you get efficient
navigation it's a tree with a high
branching factor
right so you can imagine that you know
there's this root node and you say okay
i'm looking for e
i'm looking in the avt index i'm looking
for the e of one two three oh okay looks
like
zero to one hundred is down this branch
okay i get to the second node and then
you know
uh or whatever right you can navigate
down efficiently to the to the place of
the index you're you're
looking for okay now the segments are
immutable
once a index segment is put into the
index it never changes
right which is awesome for caching right
there's nothing like immutability for
caching
it also means that nobody can ever
change the database out from underneath
you
right you've got a route you know that
everything the route points to is never
going to change
so you can just hang on to it and you
can do stable query for as long as you
want
it also means that every transaction
conceptually creates a new route
by creating new segments as needed so
anytime we need to
put a new datum in the middle of an
existing segment we
maybe have to bust that segment into two
create two or you know
that old one stays there but you create
two new segments but you can share
segments that haven't changed okay in a
point of fact that's not actually done
on every transaction
right the atomic is more clever about
its implementation
but you can notionally think of it that
way so indexes are arranged in trees
when you want to add data the best case
is that you just say okay there's a new
route
in pink here and well it's pretty much
the same as the old thing except there's
new stuff at the end so i just need to
create
one new route segment one maybe one new
intermediate segment one new leaf
segment
and then point to all the old existing
ones and notice that people can continue
to use the old one no problem nothing
has changed
and people that want an updated view of
the database can come along and use this
route
um one thing to be careful of course is
that um
you know i'm going to talk about that
right now we'll come back to the end so
let's come back to our problem now that
we understand how the atomic stores
index is and i
it really is that's straightforward an
index is a sorted set of datums
here are the sort orders you know which
datums wind up in each one
we went ahead and tried to write a query
this is data log i don't have time to go
into data log
but it's the query language that
daytonic offers couple interesting
points here
first of all this is a four-way join
fits on one slide
that's pretty awesome right i mean it's
relatively painless
again i want to go to the syntax the
other thing i want to point out here is
that
we have arbitrary closure code running
in here here's a little bit of code
closure code and i should point out that
daytonic is
usable from any jvm language i happen to
use closure but that's not
a limitation or a requirement but what i
have here is is code that is running
closure code is part of the query right
pretty neat um and you can kind of see
what's going on here now right because
what do we say
i mean again without going too deep into
data log what have we got here we've
said okay well i'm looking for some
datum that has an things that start with
a question mark or stuff that we don't
necessarily know to begin with
that has some e the attribute is room
key hotel id
and the and the v is hotel id which is
actually passed in
so which index would this clause use
well we know a and we know v
so what would be the ideal index to use
avet
right because it's efficient if you know
the a and the v you can go right to the
part you need
so what do we know about this attribute
it better be marked index true right or
else there is no
avet index for those datums and then we
have to traverse one of the other
indexes to find the datums that we care
about
okay the other thing i would like to
point out about this is that it didn't
work
okay uh that query if you ran it over
all 250 million datums that we cared
about in order to get an answer
took way too long um and way too long
here was defined by our requirement to
have an answer
back in 100 milliseconds right which is
obviously extremely aggressive for that
amount of data
and the problem is that there's no query
order that we could pick that eliminates
enough data one of the things that falls
out of
understanding how daytonic stores the
information
you can you can kind of see how since
there is currently no optimizer for data
queries having data in the right order
really helps you
because if you can start out with a
clause each of these uh
lines after the where is a clause if you
can start out with a clause
that narrows the data way way way way
down um then
you depending on your query you can
really win later on by having fewer
things you need to determine in order to
get a uh
to get a a good res uh a quick result
um that's totally gonna depend on your
data for us there was no
query order like we we did make that
mistake but
even after we optimized it
there was still no career that was going
to get us the answer to
for this arbitrary set of hotels tell me
a count of everything by event type in
the last 30 days it just it just wasn't
going to work
so after doing a little more thinking
and getting some help from rich
we were able to take another approach
that did work um
and along the way uh we wound up using a
feature of daytona that's pretty cool
that i want to mention
especially because it was part of our
solution now in order to talk about that
i need to talk a little bit about entity
ids remember we talked about the fact
that
entities you know the e in that tuple is
actually a number
and that number has two parts high bits
and low bits
the high bits are something called the
partition
which is a user assigned you don't
actually assign a number
you can you can allocate partitions in
daytonic which i should point out
is not about reserving disk space or
doing anything with storage
it's just about saying logically right
there is this thing called a partition
which is really just associated with a
number we don't get to know what the
number is but
it's going to be the high bits of entity
ids that we're creating
okay and then the low bits are a
time-like component so it's effectively
a number that goes up
over time so why would we want to do
this well think about it
the the indexes are sorted you know in
some order
take the eavt index sorted first by e
if you can say all event
entities have an e whose high
bits are the same as all other event
entities
and whose high bits are different than
hotel entities
what have you done in the index you've
grouped
all the datums by entity type or by
whatever criteria you want
right you're saying i i get to say
you know not what the high bits are but
which entities have the same high bits
right so you can that's
a it's a partition in the sense of being
a subset of all the
datums in the index and you can have
quite a large number of
partitions in our system we partition by
our notion of entity type so there's a
partition for hotels
a partition for events actually building
a new version of the system wherein we
actually partition by
event type okay
you do whatever whatever makes sense to
you and again it's really about grouping
datums in the index
so that when you traverse over the index
whether it's via query or this other
mechanism i'm going to mention
that i'm going to mention um you get
efficient traversal
make sense okay
all right so what now that we understand
that what did we actually wind up doing
well
a big win for us was to realize that in
a database where you only ever
add things and where the data is
immutable
i mean particularly for event data where
we're only ever creating
new entities for events because an event
happens we record information about it
and we never have to go back and say
additional things about that entity we
can cash we can cash
like crazily right if we have the answer
for yesterday
there's nothing that's going to happen
today that's going to change any of the
counts
of the events about yesterday or the day
before et cetera and so forth
we start to populate that cache and for
our particular data set
we could not achieve our performance
requirements
via query so we actually
used an api that daytonic provides
called seek datums
okay what does seek datums do seek
datums gives you an iterator over
one of the indexes over actually any of
the indexes you say which index you want
to iterate over
you get back a java lang iterable which
is fast
it's lazy and it's reducible in the in
the sense of closure core reducers if
you're familiar with that
which is another way of saying fast so
this is really great because we can walk
up to the index
and we can say boop start here and just
go forward
and build our summaries put them in the
cache and then use the cache to answer
questions
and we were actually able to do that um
quickly enough that in our application
we simply do that when the application
comes up and then again every time we
feel like updating it we don't
actually even need to bother persisting
like in the sense of putting it on disk
or in memcache or something somewhere
the cache data it's cheap enough for our
purposes to simply build that
when the process comes up okay the only
other piece we need to do that was we
need another api called ntid
at you give it a time and a partition
and it gives you an entity id and why
would you want that because you need to
know where you're going to start
uh in the in the index we're using the
eavt index so
given a partition which is essentially
the high bits of the entity id
and a time remember the low bits are a
time-like component it will fabricate
a an e-value that we can say yep that's
something that corresponds to
that is either equivalent to or before
the very first
event entity for such a date which is
what allows us to
you know zip over the cache starting
from an arbitrary date so we can
we can chop up our um our our index by
date which is really handy
okay here's a little fragment of actual
code from the
uh from the application it's a function
that takes
a database and this is typical in um the
atomic applications that you pass around
the database
the database is the index root
notionally right
because that's that's how you get to all
the segments for that particular value
of the database database
uh you give it some partition you give
the start date and end date we fabricate
entity ids that correspond to that start
date and that end date
then we call seek datums we tell which
database we're enumerating over
we tell it which index and then we give
it an e we could optionally give it an a
a v and even a t it starts enumerating
at that point in the index and we do
whatever we want here i just
throw in a little code that says well
we're just going to take we're just
going to take datums until
the e goes past um the
the entity id that corresponds to the
last event for that day
right and then we have other code that
takes the you know this
that comes back and reduces it into the
summary that we want and then we store
it off in a big cache
this makes sense all right why shouldn't
you just always do this this sounds
super awesome
what do you give up you give up a lot
actually you give up
uh joins for one thing and you saw how
um joins are relatively pain free in
data log i wish i had
more time to talk to you about data log
but you also give up a bunch of other
things like you give up the fact that
our query i mean this is essentially our
query now which is a bunch of closure
code
whereas before if i if we could have
pulled it off this way our query is data
um and if you've had any exposure to the
closure world you know that we
really really really like data because
data is really powerful data all the
things right
so that's another thing you give up um
the other thing is
you know you're walking away from the
implementation of data log
not only now but everything that it
could become so
you really have to kind of take this
into consideration
the other thing i would say is that you
know you should absolutely not look at
this and go
query is slow therefore we should use
seek datums right
query was uh problematic for the shape
of our data that we were using
um but you know the data is immutable
it's cached when you pull it in these
segments which are you know efficient
chunks that we pull back
and machines today have a boatload of
memory
a boatload or even like a really cheesy
ec2 medium has like three gigs of memory
there's a pretty good chance that um
maybe not all your database will fit in
memory
but a good chunk of it and guess what if
you're
if you're using the aevt index
right those datums are organized by
attribute
first and so if you have an a
a user entity that has first name last
name social security number blah blah
blah blah
but you only care about first name and
last name
you probably only need to cache the
segments of the aevt index
that are about first name and last name
and the rest of the database
can just hang out in storage right and
if that's the case then your query is
happening over memory
and so you need to take that into
consideration as well when you think
about when you think about performance
like this
so i think there's this is a really good
technique to know about but i i would
definitely
uh not advise people to start there
all right like i said we had a lot to
talk about only 40 minutes but i think
we
covered pretty good i sort of mentioned
room key again they were super awesome
to a even let me talk about this and b
to work with and then a few people on
the atomic team that
uh help with the slides so i think that
takes me over i don't have time to
answer questions up here but i'd be
happy to catch anybody in the hall or
afterwards so
thanks